j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous
on va parler de mathématiques je suis
sûr que vous gardez tous le meilleur
souvenir de vos cours de maths à l'école
n'est ce pas et pourtant vous n'êtes pas
tous devenus mathématicienne au
mathématicien
mais peut-être aurait-il suffit d'une
toute petite perturbation une rencontre
avec un professeur ou un chercheur
passionné ou un livre qui aurait piqué
votre curiosité pour qu'il en soit
autrement
bon je devine que certains d'entre vous
aurez tout de même eu besoin d'une assez
grosses perturbations
en 1972 le météorologue
r2 rade lawrence étaient invités à
présenter ses travaux dans un colloque
prestigieux mais il tarde est un peu
envoyez titre alors l'organisateur
précédent voyez le titre aux
intervenants choisit lui même ce titre
prédictibilité un battement d'aile de
papillon au brésil
peut-il engendré une tornade au texas
l'effet papillon venait de naître une
toute petite perturbation et
possiblement de très grandes
conséquences
alors l'idée connu un vif succès on la
retrouve dans le cinéma la littérature
la musique est peut-être l'avez-vous
même déjà vécu je remonte chez moi
chercher le téléphone portable que j'ai
oublié les portes du train se referme
devant moi nos regards se croisent mais
je ne rencontre pas l'amour de ma vie
donc cette idée de l'effet papillon
comme je vous l'aï dit on la retrouve
dans la littérature la musique le cinéma
quelle belle image poétique que celle du
petit papillon si fragile ayant une
influence sur le monde
alors vous allez parler poincaré voici
ce qu'écrit poincaré un dixième de degré
en plus ou en moins et le site
clown éclatent ici et non pas là et il
est temps ses ravages surtout très qu'il
si on avait connu ce dixième de degré on
aurait pu le savoir davance mais les
observations n'était assez serré ni
assez précise et c'est pour cela que
tout semble dû à l'intervention du
hasard mais alors que faire renoncer à
faire des prédictions
pourtant depuis galilée et puis newton
pour ne citer que la science nous a
habitués à faire des prédictions
redoutable si je lâche cette
télécommande par exemple elle va tomber
et finir par terre bon là il n'y a
peut-être pas besoin de convoquer
galilée newton pour faire cette
prédiction mais à partir de là avec
newton on a appris à calculer la durée
de la chute puis ensuite à calculer les
orbites des planètes à lancer un engin
spatial pour le poser sur mars wall
arrimé à la station internationale elle
même lancé à folle allure autour de la
terre mais dans d'autres systèmes plus
complexes peut-être le résultat semble
due au hasard comme quand on lance un dé
par exemple le résultat d'un lancer des
semble aléatoire mais pourtant il n'ya
rien d'aléatoire dans le mouvement d'un
dea ce mouvement est soumis aux mêmes
équations de la physique qui sont tout à
fait déterministe et pourtant si je
lance un dé il y a comme un hasard
apparent alors
prochaine fois que vous irez jouer au
loto si la personne devant vous voyez
qu'elle joue 1 2 3 4 5 6 ce n'est pas un
fou c'est juste un mathématicien dont je
ne peux donc pas prévoir le lancer le
résultat du lancer d'un dea mais je peux
quand même dire quelque chose c'est que
si le des n'est pas pipés et si je fais
un très grand nombre de lancers et bien
je verrai apparaître à peu près autant
de 1 que de 2 que de 3 que de 6 il y a
comme de l'ordre derrière le chaos
alors c'est cette vision positive de la
théorie du chaos que lawrence va
développer et que j'aimerais essayer de
vous expliquer maintenant à partir de
quelques images que j'ai réalisé en
collaboration avec deux collègues
mathématicien etienne jce et jose laisse
donc nous allons parler du modèle jouer
de convection de lawrence donc dans les
années 60 lawrence étudier le mouvement
de l'atmosphère et le phénomène de
convection
mais comment comprendre un système aussi
complexe pour comprendre l'atmosphère
il faudrait connaître la température en
tout point de la terre la pression
l'humidité vraiment vraiment trop
compliqué alors ce que fit lawrence
c'est qu'ils prient les équations de la
mécanique des fluides et ils simplifiant
simplifiée simplifiée a tellement qu'il
obtient finalement un modèle par lequel
il ne restait plus que trois paramètres
pour décrire l'état de l'atmosphère et
cette attaque cette atmosphère était
soumise à une toute petite équation
différentielle lawrence avait la chance
dans les années 60 de travail et om
haïti dans le massachussetts et avait à
sa disposition l'un des tout premiers
ordinateurs un royal magpies rien à voir
avec nos ordinateurs d'aujourd'hui qui
tiennent dans le coin d'une poche il
faut imaginer une machine assez
gigantesque extrêmement bruyante
difficile à programmer
et ne faisant dit-on qu'une dizaine de
multiplication par seconde alors
lawrence mis son modèle dans cet
ordinateur
et devinez ce qu'il en sortie quelque
chose d'absolument incroyable un lapin
maintenant il en sortit une série de
nombres les deux chiffres absolument
interminables et indigeste
alors ce qu'on peut essayer de faire
aujourd'hui c'est essayer de visualiser
ces nombres alors rappelez vous
l'atmosphère de lawrence sur cet écran
c'est un point et quand on étudie le
mouvement de l'atmosphère dans le modèle
de laurens cela revient à déplacer le
point sur l'écran je vais vous faire
voir ça dans un instant donc comprenez
bien ça deux points sur l'écran
distinctes représente a priori deux
atmosphère complètement différente
vous pouvez imaginer que sur la droite
délai de l'écran ce sont les atmosphère
calme et ensoleillé et sur la gauche
les atmosphères pluvieuse est agitée
alors je simplifie évidemment énormément
les choses mais garder à l'idée que
c'est à peu près comme ça qu'on calcule
le temps qu'il fera demain par exemple
on récupère des tas et des tas et à
données sur la température pression
humilité ça correspond à un point sur
l'écran puis on lance le modèle il va
faire un calcul pendant quelques minutes
mais qui simule les temps le temps sur
24 heures on attend ces quelques minutes
de simulation cela fait un nouveau point
sur l'écran donc une autre atmosphère et
c'est ça qu'on annonce dans le bulletin
météo très bien alors maintenant
imaginons la seule chose suivante
imaginons que le grand horloger qui gère
le temps dans l'univers fasse une pause
tout s'arrête tout se fige
plus rien ne bouge quitte à avoir
beaucoup d'imagination
prenons une deuxième planète terre
totalement figée également au même
instant sur cette deuxième planète terre
je vous propose d'introduire un peu une
petite perturbation
disons un pas
lyon au brésil qui ferait un battement
d'aile et laissons notre grand horloger
relancer le temps que constate-t-on
disons que la no2 planétaire l'une des
atmosphères est représenté par cette
petite boule verte est l'hôte cette
petite boule bleue alors au départ les
deux trajectoires sont extrêmement
proches il est absolument impossible de
voir la moindre différence mais au bout
d'un moment pas très long d'ailleurs les
petites perturbations s'amplifie elle
s'amplifie tellement qu'au bout d'un
certain temps les trajectoires
deviennent complètement indépendantes
l'une de l'autre ce que cela vous montre
c'est que le modèle de lawrence rend
bien compte de l'effet papillon une
toute petite différence au départ tout à
fait insignifiante et à la fin de
grandes conséquences des trajectoires
très différentes mais il y à beaucoup
mieux
prenons à présent deux atmosphères a
priori distinctes et assez éloignées
l'une de l'autre et lançons le mouvement
on observe à nouveau que ces
trajectoires évoluent chacune dans leur
coin de manière tout à fait indépendante
nous allons arrêter le temps et ensuite
nous allons effacer les premières
secondes du mouvement puis nous allons
rallumer le temps et on va l'accélérer
même et observons ce qui se passe que
constate-t-on que les deux trajectoires
sont complètement folle elle tourner
d'un côté de l'autre de manière assez
chaotique mais elles sont comme attiré
elles accumulent sur le même objet c'est
ce qu'on appelle la tracteur la tracteur
étrange de lawrence qui en plus a la
particularité de ressembler un papillon
alors voici un phénomène scientifique
positif qui n'est malheureusement pas
aussi célèbre que l'effet papillon
être que les trajectoires sont attirés
sur le même objet me même si vous partez
de conditions initiales très différentes
alors les mathématiciens qui sont
spécialistes de la théorie des systèmes
dynamiques étudie ce genre d' attracteur
il cherche à comprendre leur topologie
leur dynamique interne sont sympas nos
jouets non mais il ya mieux encore
encore plus fort reprenons le modèle de
laurens
encore une fois je vous rappelle qu'un
point sur l'écran cela représente l'état
complet d'une atmosphère
vous voyez cette boule jaune décidons
que quand on est un point à l'intérieur
de la boule jaune cela correspond à une
atmosphère dans lequel il y a un humour
un ouragan ou une tornade quelque part
et si vous prenez un point à l'extérieur
de l'écran à l'extérieur de la boule
jaune pardon il n'y a pas de tornades
lançons une trajectoire par exemple
celle ci envers il ya absolument
impossible de dire quand est ce que la
trajectoire va rentrer dans la boue
jones étant dit c'est à dire quand est
ce qu'il y aura une tornade dans votre
atmosphère alors ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va compter le temps qu'on passe
dans la boue john par rapport à la durée
totale de la trajectoire et c'est ce que
vous dessine ce grave sur l'écran
fonction du temps et vous voyez que au
départ pas grand chose à dire mais on
constate que progressivement que ça
converge vers une limite sur l'écran en
lits environ 5%
cela signifie que même si votre
trajectoire a l'air de faire n'importe
quoi elle passe 5 % du temps dans votre
boule jaune
prenons une deuxième trajectoire rouge
cette fois ci qui n'a aucun rapport et
faisant exactement le même calcul
comptons le temps passé dans la boue
john par la trajectoire rouge et
regardant cette proportion à nouveau on
obtient un graff qui au départ pas grand
chose à dire mais qui convergent à
nouveau et qui convergent vers la même
limite même 5%
essayons encore avec une troisième
trajectoire est bien le même phénomène
assure
produire le temps passé dans la boue
john convergent vers une limite
mais c'est la même limite ces fameux 5%
alors voici ce qu'écrit lawrence
j'avance l'idée qu'au fil des années les
petites perturbations ne modifie pas la
fréquence d'apparition des événements
tels que les tornades
la seule chose qu'ils peuvent faire
c'est de modifier l'ordre dans lequel
ces événements se produisent à cause de
votre téléphone portable tout à l'heure
vous avez manqué de faire une belle
rencontre
mais peut-être qu'à cause de ce même
événement
une rencontre que vous n'auriez pas dû
faire dans trois semaines aura lieu
l'effet papillon est omniprésent mais
l'idée de lorraine si vous voulez c'est
que le nombre de belles rencontres que
chacun d'entre nous est susceptible de
faire dans une année disons lui est à
peu près constant ce nombre dépend de
chacun d'entre nous dépend de vos
personnalités de vos sorties de vos
goûts etc
c'est cela correspondait à sur notre
dessin tout à l'heure à la taille de la
boule jaune
donc il est vrai que je ne peux pas vous
dire quand est ce que vous ferez une
prochaine belles rencontres
mais si ce nombre vos 5 pour vous disons
et bien je peux vous garantir que vous
ferez cinq belles rencontres par an
d'accord je vous avais promis une
théorie positive du chaos la voici
alors la démarche de lawrence peut vous
sembler peut-être un peu curieuse partir
d'un vrai problème de météorologie pour
le transformer et en étudier un tout
autre qui n'a qu'un rapport aux vagues
avec le premier mais que voulez-vous les
mathématiciens sont comme les français
quoique vous leur dites il le transforme
dans leur propre langue et le transforme
en quelque chose de complètement
différent
ce faisant lawrence nous invite à nous
poser d'autres questions
en dessous on ne se demandera plus le
temps qu'il fera chambord dans dix ans
jour pour jour se demandera plutôt le
nombre de jours de pluie
les températures moyennes sur une région
comme la nôtre dans une dizaine d'années
changement complet de perspectives vous
voyez il s'agit désormais de calculer
des probabilités des statistiques des
moyennes et l'idée de lawrence c'est que
ces probabilités sont invariante aux
petites perturbations
les papillons brésilien n'y peuvent rien
alors je voudrais terminer en insistant
sur le fait que le temps de la science
est long très long
le monde de newton hérité de celui des
grecs anciens faisait la part belle aux
phénomènes périodiques le fait que le
soleil par exemple se lève à peu près
toutes les 24 heures que votre coeur bat
à peu près régulièrement vous 60-70
pulsations par minute
moi c'est un petit peu plus là tout de
suite donc faisait la part belle aux
phénomènes périodiques et aux attracteur
simple si je lâche cette télécommande
après une courte période transitoire
elle finira par terre au sol aussi a
qu'une seule chose à retenir mon exposé
c'est quand même ça hein c'est un
principe fort et 200 ans après newton
poincaré découvre d'autres dynamiques
c'est la naissance de la théorie du
chaos alors quel est le comportement le
plus fréquent dans la nature les
attracteurs simple comme un pendule qui
oscille et finit par s'arrêter ou des
attaques ou des dynamiques plus
compliqué qui amplifie les petites
perturbations comme quand on lance un dé
et que le résultat semble due au hasard
là on a quelques idées en vrai même on a
un certain nombre de conjectures mais on
n'a pas une idée et un paysage
complètement clair alors peut-être
vous demanderez vous pourquoi est ce
utile d'étudier tout ça je pourrais
essayer de vous donner plusieurs bonnes
raisons et vous convaincre que c'est
important mais à vrai dire la vraie
raison notre vraie motivation
leonardo en parlait déjà il y a cinq
cents ans quand il écrivait que le
plaisir le plus noble et la joie de
comprendre le plaisir le plus noble et
la joie de comprendre je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]